[Music]
okay how did we get from this
to this it's pretty amazing yeah a lot
happens in 10 years like Blue Ivy Carter
gaining on Mom Beyonce in the height
Department this makes me proud the
cuffet singer dropped some new picks on
the gram celebrating their family affair
at the Waco theater's wearable art Gala
in a rare snapshot of the two it's clear
Blue's on her way to one day be eye to
eye with her iconic mama who run the
world girls elsewhere in the dump we've
got J and B understanding the assignment
going all out for the Harlem Nights
theme it's just pretty and this is an
error I think I would have done well in
and we can't ignore Beyonce's epic
family portrait with nephew Jules up top
Jay at her right blue taking Center and
opposite Mom Tina Knowles Lawson and
husband Richard this is Miss Tina's
favorite era Tina and Richard co-founded
the gala where some big names stepped
out to raise money for the theater's
mentorship program I'm so proud of Miss
Tina and Mr Richard and everything that
they're doing it makes me emotional
because this you know we've been
dreaming about this for a year and
playing it and just to see it come to
fruition everybody looks so beautiful
all the performers were so gracious to
fly here from across the world to be
here tonight and we just feel very
supported as for blue her support came
by way of the live auction
thank you
of course her parents were on hand to
supervise their little ones star-studded
bidding war Tina called a few weeks ago
and I said yes did you buy some art
while you were there didn't have a
chance Blue Ivy sitting there with the
paddle and I was like kid's gonna come
at me tonight looking like she's 21 man
girls growing up so quickly and said
we're getting old well blue passed on
the yard
but she did set her sights on a pair of
Lorraine Schwartz diamond earrings once
owned by her mom
[Music]
me when I'm calling you
but at night's end blue lost out
[Music]
no she didn't take home the earrings but
we know Grandma has plenty of reasons to
be proud of her she's quite a makeup
artist is she yeah she's amazing she
puts stones and does all this fancy
stuff she can do a perfect cat eye it's
just for play time okay we have fun
foreign